hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain an American Comedy drama film
called yes God yes spoilers ahead watch
out and take care
[Music]
the movie is set in the year 2000 in the
first scene we are introduced to Alice a
shy and innocent teenager who studies at
a strict Catholic High School the place
is so strict that many students stop
coming after the first few days stop
coming indeed the disciplined teacher
makes sure to check all the girls
minutely when it comes to appearance she
even measures their skirts to verify if
they are of appropriate length the
school is also notorious for its
ultra-religious beliefs lying is
considered a sin and watching romantic
movies is deemed punish worthy
especially if they star A young John
Cusack While most of the students agree
with it Alice who is going through an
intense adolescence face is confused she
is very curious about erotic stuff the
school's principal father Murphy usually
takes sex ed classes where he explains
that coitus without the purpose of
reproduction is a sin one day a curious
student inquires of self-coitus I.E
jacking off is illegal father Murphy
simply cross-questions him does that
produce babies to which I'd have said it
produces Maybe babies he also makes it
clear that any form of intercourse
before marriage will result in
Everlasting misery Alice has a hard time
comprehending all of this as her sexual
desires keep growing with every class on
one hand her teacher strictly advises
her against those fantasies but on the
other hand her body needs it she becomes
even more confused when her best friend
Laura doesn't support her feelings the
latter believes that students their age
should simply focus on their studies
later when Alice reaches home she
immediately sits next to her computer
and opens the popular online chat room
AOL oh man that makes me feel old as she
is going through various rooms she
suddenly gets a message from an unknown
guy by the username Harry chest
1956. he has sent some unsolicited and
explicit images of him doing it with his
wife Alice who has never seen such
pictures before immediately turns off
the monitor in disgusts but shortly
after curiosity gets the better of her
so she turns on the Monitor and starts
scrolling through the images this is how
all perverts online like to imagine it
goes minutes later Harry chest 1956
again messages her he wants to know her
ASL Alice doesn't know what that means
so he explains it to her in detail after
Alice lies that she is a 22 year old
girl from Iowa the man asks her for a
picture slightly scared she sends him a
photo of her friend Instead This excites
the man even more so he starts sending
her erotic messages Alice just reads and
bewilderment as she doesn't understand
most of the words as the chat continues
the man inquires if she is pleasuring
herself Alice has never done it before
but when the man reassures her that it's
fine she slides her hand inside all of a
sudden Alice starts feeling wonderful
but before she can climax her mother
arrives home she hardly turns off the
Monitor and rushes towards the kitchen
what's for dinner mom smells hot I mean
the next day at school as Allison and
Laura are having lunch in the cafeteria
a popular girl approaches them and says
I cannot believe Alice tossed Wade's
salad she also mentions that the entire
school is buzzing with this rumor
however Alice denies doing that saying
she doesn't even know what the phrase
means I'll give you a hint Alice that
salad contained nuts she also asserts
that she never talks to Wade the nerdy
classmate who always looks high after
the popular girl leaves Alice takes out
the cover of a chocolate filling and
starts licking it unsurprisingly this
makes the guys nearby burst out in
laughter Wade and his girlfriend also
arrived there and call Alice disgusting
later the discipline teacher hears about
the rumor and forbids Alice from serving
during mass she also warns the teenager
to be careful as God is watching her in
the evening Alice who is feeling guilty
about the AOL chat incident confesses
her venial crimes to Father Murphy the
latter does not scold her but he simply
asks her to refrain from such things as
a form of punishment he tells her to
recite the prayer 20 times which she
instantly does oh man don't stop says
father Murphy in the next scene both
Alice and Laura decide to attend the
school's upcoming Retreat where the
students will be taught how to get
closer to God Alice sees this as the
perfect opportunity to return to the
path of righteousness while Laura wants
to be noticed by a popular senior named
Nina when they arrive at the campgrounds
Alice cannot take her eyes off of a
retreat leader Chris who also happens to
be the captain of the school football
team he's just one t-shirt of Christ
maybe I'll let him touch mine on the
other hand Laura is excited to finally
see Nina who is another Retreat leader
but the two get selected in the opposite
groups making them both upset later Nina
leads Alice to a room and asks her to
hand over all her gadgets and devices
Alice hands her watch but she keeps her
phone with herself the next morning all
the students gather in the main hall
where father Murphy starts one of his
boring lectures he says that they have
been summoned to this trip by none other
than the almighty God himself once the
students survive his lecture they are
asked to take part in a survey in a form
a variation of feelings are mentioned
and the students will have to circle the
ones they've felt throughout the year
Alice circles some of them along with
the word turned on after the time is up
though she has a change of thoughts she
tries to erase the circle over turned on
but can't so she simply crosses out the
word before submitting the form for the
next exercise the students are asked to
come on stage and express anything they
want to say Nina takes this as the
perfect opportunity to become the center
of Attraction she goes on about how her
family ignored her when she was a kid
the plan works and all the students
circle her and give her a warm hug that
night as Alice is sneakily using her
cell phone she suddenly gets an idea she
puts the device on vibration mode and
then shoves it between her legs Alice
suddenly starts having butterflies in
her stomach and a weird sensation she
has never felt before however when she
sees the crucifix hanging in her room
she stops I guess she's not into
voyeurism just yet on the second day of
the retreat all the students are taken
on a hike through the woods a girl
accidentally trips so Chris helps syrup
elegantly this gives Alice an idea so
she fakes an injury and calls him for
help he immediately goes to her picks
her up and takes her to a nurse Alice is
over the moon in her mind she is having
multiple hormonal explosions The Retreat
is turning out to be a good one for her
so far but unfortunately in the evening
Nina finds out about her cell phone when
it unexpectedly starts vibrating it is
immediately confiscated and Alice is
sent to Father Murphy as a punishment he
assigns her to cleaning duties Around
The Retreat House Alice obliges and
starts cleaning right away a few hours
later while she's still at it she
notices a computer inside Father
Murphy's room since there is no one
around Alice silently opens his computer
and logs onto AOL anonymously then she
inquires what tossing the salad actually
means unfortunately the people in the
chat room give her different answers and
none of them seem to be conclusive it
means drawing off the leaves it means
mixing up the ingredients it means
blowing yourself at the same time Alice
hears some footsteps approaching so she
hastily turns off the monitor not
realizing that the computer is still
open on her way out she runs into Nina
who lightheartedly guilts Alice about
her presumed encounter with Wade Nina
further adds that she is not mad at her
for illegally sneaking in her phone
instead she is hopeful that Alice is on
the right path towards righteousness on
the third day Chris gathers a bunch of
students and asks them to confess their
regrets if they have any he says that
confessions help people relieve their
stress and stay focused one by one all
the students explain their SOB stories
one talks about his recent breakup with
his girlfriend while another mentions
how she couldn't attend her
grandmother's funeral when it's Alice's
turn she says she wants to grate some
cheese on Chris's sweet ABS but actually
she has nothing to say so she just lies
that her dog was poisoned to death and
she couldn't save him the story touches
one of the students so deeply that she
starts crying later as all the students
are in the cafeteria father Murphy shows
up with an anxious look and reveals that
someone accessed explicit content on his
computer he then tells the culprit to
claim responsibility soon as possible
when no one utters a word he leaves
saying his favorite catchphrase God is
watching the incident frightens Alice
but she decides to keep her secret
concealed in the next scene all the
students are called to Father Murphy's
office one by one he wants to check if
they are making progress soon it's
Alice's turn and the first thing she has
asked about is her relationship with God
she simply replies it's good after this
Murphy asks her why she circled the word
turned on Alice explains that she felt
it before coming to this retreat but now
she feels nothing before leaving father
Murphy talks about her rumor with Wade
and even presses her to confess to it
sus but Alice who still doesn't know
what the actual rumor is tells him that
she is innocent the same day as Alice is
cleaning the cafeteria Wade decides to
wind her up by littering around she
angrily asks him what his problem is but
before he can answer father Murphy
arrives there and takes him away shortly
after when Alice resumes her cleaning
she finds Wade's bracelet which he had
dropped earlier she puts it in her
pocket and heads to the kitchen where
she notices something shocking Nina is
kissing and then fellating a random guy
in the woods Alice has left and utter
disbelief but she is also harassed hence
she puts the mop handle between her
thighs and calms her hormones hi sodomy
recapped here once she is done she
rushes to her best friend Laura and
shares what she saw however the latter
refuses to believe her instead she
chastises Alice for saying such evil
things about her Idol Nina she even
accuses her of using AOL on the father's
computer and calls her a pervy psycho
fed up with everyone trying to judge her
Alice goes straight into Father Murphy's
office and plants Wade's bracelet under
the keyboard but before she can leave
Murphy returns forcing her to hide
inside the closet surprisingly the Holy
Father starts knocking one out to some
adult content he has stored in his holy
computer Alice who witnesses everything
is so disgusted that she closes her eyes
and turns her head around yeah
confession is gonna be good this week
outside she meets Chris who asks her if
she is okay he also insists on talking
to her to make her feel good Alice
thinks he is into her so she kisses him
passionately unfortunately Chris finds
it very weird and runs away crying at
night when everyone is busy with their
prayers Alice sneaks out to the
campgrounds to have some fresh air she
stumbles upon a lesbian bar where she
and the owner Gina commiserate about how
the fear of damnation can warp an
adolescent's development the teenager
asks Gina about why everyone raps around
a fake image to impress others and hide
who they really are she further adds
that she is afraid to explore and commit
small mistakes afraid of the fact that
she will go to hell seeing her depressed
Gina reveals her own story she explains
that she was also brought up in a
Catholic school where the rules were
extremely strict however she didn't let
them change her and now she is a totally
different person than what was expected
of her hearing this Alice becomes
somewhat happy after their conversation
ends Gina gives her a ride back to the
retreat she also encourages her to look
into colleges that are much more
open-minded but before she returns Alice
has one last question she wants to know
the meaning of tossing someone's salad
Gina laughs for a while and finally
reveals that it means licking someone's
rest Alice also pretends to laugh but
deep down she is horrified on the last
day of the retreat as all the students
are having breakfast father Murphy
abruptly pulls Wade away turns out that
his bracelet has been found making him
the perpetrator in the Father's Eyes
with this Laura also makes peace with
Alice and Promises to not judge her
again surprisingly she also reveals that
Wade is gay he simply spread the rumor
of Alice tossing his salad in order to
conceal his true identity
if Wade wanted a convincing lie maybe he
shouldn't have made it about his wreck
later in the sharing session Wade is
made to apologize for all the horrific
atrocities he's committed once he has
done father Murphy asks if anyone else
wants to go next Alice immediately
volunteers and begins Her speech she
explains that everyone has something to
hide but that doesn't make them a bad
person some things are best unsaid she
also encourages everyone to not follow
rumors and respect everyone equally just
like Jesus did Jesus is hot she says he
may not have hair as good as Steve's but
I hear he knows how to Smite following
this the scene skips to a few days later
at school Alice runs into Chris but he
is still uneasy about the earlier
incident he thinks that Alice will kiss
him again but when she promises that she
just wants to be friends he calms down
that evening Alice heads to the
reconciliation room with Father Murphy
where she nonchalantly reveals that she
watched an adult video during the
retreat when she starts explaining the
specifics of the video father Murphy
realizes that it's his favorite one both
of them know what's up but they do not
about it before leaving Alice asks if
she will get punished for watching the
explicit content and Murphy with shame
in his eyes says I don't know in the
final scene Alice reaches home and plays
the videotape of her favorite movie
Titanic she forwards to the intimate
scene and prepares to trigger her
hormones the movie ends as she notices a
vibrator nearby possibly belonging to
her mother what it's a weird ending
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching